All right, folks, welcome back.
This is going to be episode 24 of the continuing series of the free ICT mentorship on YouTube
for 2022.
All right, so I'm going to kind of like sit you down for a minute, get your attention
because if you don't have the proper mindset for this one, this could be taken out of context
and viewed in a light that is not really my aim.
Okay, so I want you to think about why are you even watching these videos?
Are you trying to learn?
Are you just entertaining yourself or are you here to try to be disruptive?
Because if you're trying to be disruptive, I don't have any time for that.
So I want you to understand what I'm going to show in this video.
This is not going to be a repeating theme.
I just want to let the foundation be laid here.
If I see any comments that are either disrespectful or just meant to stir up chaos and create
a ruckus, I'm just going to ban you from the channel and your posts won't appear.
The comment section is open.
You guys said I don't open the comments up.
I've been opening them up.
All the mentorship videos are open.
I use your comments to steer the future direction of the lessons.
I try to incorporate things that you may have asked or shown a concern about respectfully.
If this is not for you, then obviously you can go watch Tom, Dick, and Harry go play
in Market Replay.
Okay, that's fine.
But here, I'm teaching you things that actually work in the live markets, not pulling some
strings to make you feel like you're learning something that is a gimmick.
This is real market delivery.
Those of you that are really sincere about learning, obviously, you have a lot of work
ahead of you.
And we are in the development stages early on in this mentorship.
So that means you have to understand that this is the discovery where you see this pattern.
You're supposed to be going back through the data and your old charts, not trading, not
even demo trading, okay?
You're looking for this pattern through backtesting.
Now some of you have asked to do a backtesting episode.
I will do a backtesting episode, okay?
But I want you to understand that you have to have the proper mindset here.
You have to be responsible.
You have to be attentive and you have to listen.
So the things I'm teaching, the things I'm saying, suggesting to you, you have to make
them applicable to your own journey.
You can't just watch and think, okay, I've seen him do this a few times in a video.
I understand it.
So I'm going to go out there and try to do it.
So I want you to understand in light of that idea or direction that some of you want to
take, just know that that's not the proper way of doing it, okay?
So some of you are unaware that this is the other part of the ICT experience.
So when I'm communicating to the community here, not only am I doing it in the comment
section very, very rarely, but I also talk on the community posts.
And if you go on the YouTube, go to my YouTube channel and click on this little area here,
you'll see it's kind of like my Twitter, like my update area.
Sometimes I'll prompt you to look at certain charts or I'll encourage you, give you ideas
to think about where you are in your journey.
And sometimes I'll share a YouTube channel or a specific video.
It's not meant for you to be able to talk to me here, but you can obviously say anything
you want in the comment section.
Just know that if it's something that's disrespectful, you can say whatever you want on your last
post because I'll just make you invisible.
You won't be here anymore.
And you can keep creating accounts.
I don't care.
It just takes one little click of a button for me.
You got to go through a whole overcome a row of email addresses and all that business.
And I don't get tired of clicking, hitting ban.
I don't get tired of doing it.
It's real easy.
It's fun.
But this area here is the other segment of the mentorship.
So with that in mind, I made this post a little while ago and today's date is May 5th, 2022.
And I know some of you try to remind me to make these posts with the date.
And I just don't, I don't remember it.
I'm used to doing Twitter and Twitter used to do a time and date stamp all the time.
It's just, I'm a creature of habit like anybody else.
I don't really think about it when I'm doing it.
But I made this post this morning and I said, you know, good morning constant reader.
I know, right?
That FOMC was pretty neat, huh?
Now try this one.
Open your NASDAQ 15 minute chart and E-mini S&P 15 minute charts.
Drop a horizontal line across those smooth criminal highs in both index.
I'll explain what that is in a moment.
See how we dropped into a discount overnight?
Study how they treat those relative equal highs today and non-farm payroll Friday, as
you were.
So I'm encouraging all of you to open up your charts and interact, okay, because some of
you just want to watch my videos and that's it and think it's going to translate from
just watching and then now you know how to do it.
No.
You've got to get in and study it.
So I prompted everyone to look at their chart and this is kind of like what I was drawing
your attention to.
Now, that's one caveat here.
That little blue arrow, that is me drawing the specific, so that way we know what we're
talking about here, where my attention was really drawn in on this.
I'm watching this.
I got that little bubble there.
That little gap right there, I'm watching and I'm waiting for that to drop down at
930.
That's that little Judas swing.
Okay.
I'm waiting for that Judas swing to happen where it drops down at 930.
If it goes into that area there and then it creates displacement, then it looks for a
fair value gap.
And if it trades back down into a fair value gap inside that displacement, then I can go
long and I'll look for a run into that 4303, okay?
I did not tell my mentorship last night that I wanted to do this very thing here.
But if I was going to tell my mentorship anything, this is what I would have said, okay?
I would like to see it drop down into that area and then create the model that I'm teaching
here on the YouTube channel.
Now, read what it says here.
It says, you are studying this and I am watching this, okay?
Pray tell, does this in any manner whatsoever suggest in any manner at all that any of you
should be buying or selling this?
No, it doesn't.
For years, I've been asked to do live sessions.
I've been asked to trade live in front of people, okay?
The number one reason why I have refrained from doing it is what we're going to talk
about next.
Because responsibility is lacking predominantly across all countries, all age and demographics.
It's simply something that most people in trading lack, okay?
Now it's going to be very easy for me to sit in front of a chart and say, this is what
I think is going to happen.
I think it might go up to this level or go down to that level.
That is not a trade idea.
That's just bias.
It's logic.
That's the extent of what I'm going to do in the live sessions.
The reason why I already said that in the beginning and I didn't change gears because
of what I'm going to talk about tonight, but this is important, okay?
Mindset is absolutely crucial.
If you young guys and gals in here are already bored, do yourself a favor.
Turn this video off.
Don't ever watch another video by me because you're going to cheat yourself from the absolute
best prevention of ruin.
If you continuously try to just watch my videos, pay intermittent attention and then think
you're going to glean any real understanding because this is highly technical, I have simplified
it and you're going to see two very simplified approaches to what I'm trying to teach so
that way I can get right to the point.
But these are the parts that cause people that don't want to listen, they don't want
to pay the attention to the things I'm teaching you.
These are the parts that will hurt you if you don't understand it.
Do you want to succeed?
Because to succeed you need this part, not the little patterns, not the little things
I can draw on a chart, that stuff, that's the smallest part of it.
How you think about yourself, what you think you're capable of doing and the management
and observation and respect of risk is going to determine what your success is going to
be.
I wish I could grab you by your lapels and just shake you and say, listen, this is the
part you need to learn.
It's not full of Lamborghinis, it's not full of Patek Philippe watches and flossing in
front of everybody.
I talk to you this way because I genuinely care about your success.
That's all.
That's all I want you to be able to do is take this information, the logic and do well
with it.
I'm not trying to bore you or burn through minutes just for the sake of hearing myself
talk.
I want you to understand and some of you simply don't want to listen.
You have to be a critical thinker.
I'm training you to be a critical thinker.
I'm going to give you two examples tonight of what critical thinking is not.
This individual here was in the comment section and this is the poster child for why I do
not sit in front of people and trade with entry, stop, targets.
I don't do that because invariably someone's going to take something I'm doing or saying
or applying to a chart and they're going to do something with live funds and they're going
to come out and say, just lost a thousand, thanks a lot.
Now I don't know who this person is.
This person may not have actually taken a trade and lost money.
This person may be a troll.
This person may be a genuinely sincere individual.
At this point, I don't care, but I want to highlight this is the very thing, folks.
This is it.
This is the thing that prevented me all these years to sit in front of all of you and entertain
you with trading because someone's going to do something and when they do something by
their own actions and it's painful for them, if they lose money, guess whose fault that
is because it's not mine.
It's the person that lost the money.
Listen, everything I teach here is under the guise of demo and paper trading.
That's compliance.
I don't give trade advice.
I can talk about where the market's going to go.
I can give my opinion about that market opinions.
That's not trade advice.
It's the same logic, the same idea, and the same language that all of my paid mentorship
students sign an agreement and they give me indemnity.
They know going in that everything I'm saying is under the pretense of demo and paper trading
and you can't make money with demo trading.
But guess what?
You can't do either.
You can't lose money either.
So it gives you that freedom to think about what you're doing without the tug of war of
making and losing money.
Some of you in here are so high strung and so impatient that you just want to go out
there and say, okay, I'm going to watch this video.
I'm going to get a hint from ICT like I'm giving you some kind of secret language for
a signal service.
And I say this stuff to my own paid mentorship.
I said it for six years.
Every time there was a new group coming in and know there is no new group coming in and
stop listening to these yahoos out there saying that I'm going to start another mentorship
I'm not selling no more mentorships, folks, because of this kind of stuff.
Okay.
I'm not doing it.
So whether this person knows the thousand dollars or didn't, I don't care.
That right there is why I have prevented myself saying, no, I'm not going to do it because
I know there's going to be a lot of you out here that are going to hurt yourself because
you're not ready.
None of you should be trading this model with live funds.
We haven't even gotten through all of the content or the process of what it is you're
doing with it.
Today you're getting another piece of it.
But this is the crucial part.
This is the stuff, the boring stuff, the things that you don't want to listen to, the things
that you want to go through, the people that want to come in here later on and say, here's
a minute marker when he starts really teaching and you want to avoid the crap.
I will delete your posts if you do stuff like that.
It's disrespectful not only to me, but the other viewers because you're really taking
their attention away from what is the real lesson.
You're all entitled to your opinion, but if your opinion is disruptive or disrespectful,
I won't let it post.
Now you can disagree respectfully and those posts stay on the comment section, but nonsense
that's meant to start a ruckus, your channel will be blocked.
Then you have folks like this who cannot be taught.
Now again, this could be a troll.
This could be someone that didn't really take a trade today because really the logic, as
I'm going to prove tonight, really wasn't in the marketplace today for this model.
And it can't be argued.
There's no way you're going to be able to say that what I posted this morning is lying
about with any of the logic that this model uses.
So again, this person may have done something foolish or maybe they're just here to troll.
That's fine.
It doesn't matter because the posts that were made even after this indicate that the person's
really not properly prepared to learn how to do this and or really not interested in
learning.
So they're going to get removed.
They may come back in another form, but any disrespectful comment will be removed.
This statement right down here at the bottom highlighted, take accountability for your
actions.
If you're taking trades, number one, you got to take accountability for your actions.
Those are your actions.
I didn't reach through the screen.
I didn't go to your house.
I didn't go to your apartment.
I didn't meet you at your job and press your cell phone to get you into a trade.
In fact, I didn't tell anybody about a trade.
I said, study, watch.
I'm watching this.
That is not indications.
That's not instructions to buy or sell anything.
So don't get caught up in all this frenzy to be pushing any buttons yet because none
of you know what you're doing.
I appreciate your patience getting through that, how to get it off my chest, and I promise
I won't do it again because it's already been done here.
Just know that if you act like those individuals, I won't see your posts.
So E-mini S&P, we won't cover tonight, but it's kind of similar to what this is showing
here.
But the E-mini NASDAQ 100 futures June contract delivery month, 2022.
This is a daily chart.
I felt that this morning we could have popped through, stabbed above these relative equal
highs right in here, and then created this run lower.
That's kind of like what I was prompting.
Study that because if it happens, you can see and study in back test, now that the market's
already moved, you can go back in and look and see if the model in fact did what I teach.
This is actually a good lesson because it shows where I'm looking for something to form,
but it doesn't form.
It doesn't create a losing trade.
It doesn't get me into something that causes me to buy it when there really isn't an entry
pattern there.
This is the proof, the evidence that the model has validity.
So if you have a valid, reasonable, sound logic behind the model, whatever model that
is, then it should prevent you from taking bad trades.
Not all the time, but sometimes when there is a really big move going the other direction
that you don't see or expect, it may do its job and keep you from getting into those bad
trades.
And I'm going to show you the logic here today.
I want you to be a critical thinker.
Think about what I've already taught about this model.
In the comment section below, if you think that this model appeared based on what I showed
in that community post, say so.
If you don't think that this model appeared based on what I showed, then say so as well.
Also, I'd appreciate if you would include in your post, where are you all from, folks?
I want to get a broad range view of how far I'm reaching.
I know I've got a lot of people in different countries, but all you have to do is tell
me what country you're from.
You don't have to be specific with your address or social security number.
I'm not that interested.
But I would like to know where everyone's from.
But here's the logic with that one hour chart and that relative equal high.
So this is the framework.
I'm looking for a run above here.
If it can get above that, then what?
It could wash out and go lower.
Why would that be possible in terms of a pattern or a setup or the logic?
What would be the catalyst for that?
What was the reasoning for you being interested in these relative equal highs?
Number one, it's Thursday.
It's Thursday and it's ahead of non-farm payroll Friday.
A non-farm payroll Friday is usually a volatile day.
It can be messy.
It can be sloppy.
Sometimes it's just a really just a dud.
It doesn't really do anything.
Other days it could be extremely volatile like the FOMC.
But because FOMC has done what it's done, I don't think that the non-farm payroll numbers
is going to have that much impact.
But I was looking for these relative equal highs to be taken out, then drop lower, then
create the model that I'm teaching.
That's why it's kind of drawing your attention to them.
That way if it did present that, you can have something to study.
Now, what's the catalyst that sets the run up into those relative equal highs?
I'm going to talk about that now.
Much like I was suggesting in that post, we had dropped down into a discount.
I posted ahead of the 930 opening where equities open up and that volatility that comes in
around 930, I want to see some kind of manipulation in price.
So if our focus, and I was trying to get your attention up here, if our focus is up there
and it's dropping down and it's ahead of 930, what are we likely to see?
Drop down, get traders thinking it's going to go lower, and then rally up.
Not just go down indiscriminately and then go higher.
It's got to do something specific.
I'm interested in this area right here.
That's what I posted in that community post saying, I'm watching this, and that was that
little area right here.
For all of these videos that I've been posting, it's very specific.
I'm teaching fair value gap.
That fair value gap is right there, okay?
So dropping down into that, that would be a point of interest for me so that I can go
in and look for something that gives me my setup.
So in other words, this here is just where the trade might form.
Hear what I just said?
Where the trade might, it could, it may, not it's absolutely going to.
This is a promise.
There's no way this can fail because that logic doesn't exist in trading except for
over leverage and over trade, you're going to blow your account.
That's a guarantee, okay?
But that fair value gap, that's the place in terms of price.
Where should the pattern form?
By itself, it's just price, but we have to incorporate what element first.
Algorithmically, it's time.
So I'm teaching you elements of time at that 9.30, we're expecting some volatility.
Dropping down into that area here, which at this point in the chart, it doesn't do yet.
So I'm looking for it to drop down into that area.
If it does, then I'm going to be looking for what I teach you in this model.
So with that area shaded, right here, this is a 15-minute chart, you can see, we traded
down into it, the candle stopped right at the old candle high, and the next candle just
gave up the ghost.
Right away, we should notice that we did have the initial criteria, which is trading below
an old low, so what's going to be resting below that, sell stops.
So they go down, run out the sell stops, traders are caught in, then what?
What's the next logic?
We've got to look for displacement.
It's got to trade back above this old low.
It's got to have displacement above that.
Did it happen here?
No.
Here is a five-minute chart.
Now if you're looking at this with that same low here, it trades down below it, did we
get displacement above that old low?
No.
It just went down, consolidated, returned back to it, but melted, didn't do anything above
that old low.
There was no displacement, no energetic move, so that way you can look for a fair value
gap to trade back down into the buy.
So anyone that would have looked at this and bought today is not using what I'm teaching.
They're just impulsively pushing a button, and if they lost money, you have to fault
yourself for that.
I'm not going to be the target for all of you that fail, don't listen, and want to gamble,
and when it doesn't work for you because you took a guess, you took a stab at it, you just
wanted to see what was going to happen, and you lose money, you can never do that with
me.
Even my paid mentorships, those students, they can't do any of that either, because
I never tell them to go into anything and buy or sell anything, nothing.
I'm not going to co-sign your financial ruin, it ain't going to happen.
None of this can be placed on me, the responsibility is solely on you, the viewer, and it's a lot
of responsibility, and some of you simply are not going to be able to do this, not because
it doesn't work, but because you are not responsible.
You don't have any self-control, you don't want to listen, you don't want to have any
rules, and those rules, look at it like this folks.
In the videos, I'll suggest folks, hey look, pause the video here, study it so that way
you can really look for it before it's revealed.
There's a lot of people, they make jokes and say, I'm not going to pause the video.
I promise you, if they're sincere in their response saying that, I promise you, they
will not learn this, it will not happen, because they're showing a trait that is simply not
conducive for success in doing this business, so it doesn't work like that.
It's not easy, it's not Netflix and chill, it's ICT and study your ass off, that's the
way it is, and it takes a lot of logic that you have to adhere to.
And you have to break yourself, there's a lot of things you're going to try to do impulsively.
If you do them here and it works for you and you make profits, you're going to be in here
in the comment section high-fiving me, yeah, we're killing it ICT style, when in fact,
you just got lucky.
Because then, the next time you take another trait impulsively, you're going to want to
fault me, you're going to say you weren't around.
When I posted that comment this morning, I spent the day with my wife, I haven't seen
her for a week, and I'm not obligated to babysit anybody through a community post.
I don't even do that with my mentorship, they pay me.
So again, it's all about responsibility, and I'm placing the logic in your hands, it's
up to you to go through the charts, see if it fits you.
If it doesn't fit you folks, there's a lot of other ways to trade, there's lots of ways
to trade.
I'm biased, I believe mine's the best.
I believe I can outperform anybody in any style of trading, and I can do it consistently.
Will that translate to you?
No, but I'm saying and promising that you're going to learn how to read price better than
you ever imagined.
It's worth the investigation, look into it, see if it doesn't hold up.
But don't do things outside the rules I'm giving you, and that's why I teach this way,
slow incremental pieces, because invariably, you're going to do things impulsively if you
lack self-control.
If you don't have self-control, you're going to blow up.
And folks listen, there's nothing worse than thinking you understand something in a rush,
and then go out there and trade with live funds and blow the account.
It hurts, it's painful, it sucks.
And it's easy to say, oh, it's that guy that wasn't there to tell me what's really going
on.
If he would have told me this or that, I wouldn't have lost money, no, because I'm never putting
any of my students in that position where they have to be handheld through a trade.
They're putting their self in that if they did it at all, and they got to get themselves
out of it.
That teaches responsibility, and you have to own those results.
Good or bad, they're yours.
And that's why I tell everybody, when they find success in this and they like to say,
hey, it was all credit to you, ICT, without you, I couldn't have done this, wrong, wrong.
The only thing I did was show you how to read price.
I did not sit with you and push a button.
So if you took on that risk, if you sat through the learning and worked through all the back
testing and studying and forward testing, demoing, and producing a track record that
you can feel confident in, then and only then, with the time that you choose, not when I
say so, because I never tell anybody to trade with live funds, in fact, right now I remind
you, don't trade with live funds.
When you make that decision, should you ever do so, you've done it on your own accord.
So if you make money, whose success really is that?
It's yours and it's well deserved.
Never ever champion me for your success.
Now you can thank me for helping you with the logic, but I didn't help you make money.
And just as well, I did not help you lose it either.
Those buttons getting pushed, you pushed them and you have to sleep with yourself knowing
that that's the results that you provided and there it is, you live with it.
And if it's a bad taste in your mouth, swallow, that's the way it is.
It's bitter medicine, but it's good for you, you'll learn from it or it'll take you out
of the business and that might be the best thing for you.
If you can't stick to the rules, this game has a funny way of taking you right out of it.
The people that are consistently profitable, it's not by luck and they're not stupid.
They have a logic they adhere to, they have rules that they trade with and they have to
stick to them.
When they deviate from them or do something outside of what that rule-based strategy is,
then it's reasonable to expect ruin or loss.
And those moments are most painful because you can look back and say, this is not what
I should have done.
That's what I shared that other guy Corb's video about.
I'm sure he has a strategy, but for whatever reason, from his commentary, he suggested
that he just lost control of himself and started doing things that made no sense.
Anybody that's ever traded with live funds knows exactly what that means.
If anybody has ever traded with live funds, they understand what that man was saying.
I know, I've done a lot in the 90s, I know exactly what he was talking about.
But it feels like it's never going to work and you just want to beat yourself up.
You're going to have losing trades, folks, okay?
In your journal right now, today, with today's date, make a promise to yourself right out.
I promise that as long as I'm doing this, I'm going to endure losses.
Notice I said endure.
You're not going to be defeated by those losses.
You're just going to have to endure them because trading is all about managing losing trades.
You got to trade your way out of a losing trade.
Every single time you get into market, every single trade, as soon as you start off, you're
under the commission, you're under the spread in Forex.
You got to come out of that.
Every trader is a losing trader that finds success out of loss or suffers ruin in it.
That's it.
There are two things that can happen.
All right, so now I'll talk a little bit about the model and give you a little bit more details
and I'll probably feel like I beat you up and you're like, man, this is depressing.
This is not what I was hoping to hear.
I promise it was good stuff for you, okay?
Now I want to talk about where do these setups form.
So in your journal, this is like a subtitle area for this video, where do setups form?
Think about that for a minute.
When you're looking for this idea that I'm sharing, the fair value gap, where would you
expect them to appear in price?
Obviously, I've been teaching you to run above an old high or relative equal highs and if
you're bearish, that would set up a scenario where the market goes up, sweeps the highs,
breaks back down below the highs, short-term lows taken out with displacement and then
you go back through that displacement leg looking for a fair value gap, the short end
to.
That's pretty simple logic, isn't it?
Well, visually, I want you to understand it, okay, so that way in your mind, I do this
exercise all the time with my students, can you draw out with a diagram, like if you were
at work and you're trying to explain to your friend or co-worker what it is you're looking
for in price?
Now, they're not going to understand what you're doing, but how would you draw it out
in price or in a napkin with a pen or pencil?
What would it look like?
Well, you have obviously a level of relative equal highs and we're just going to use that
green line as an example of that and price is moving towards it, small little correction
or so and it runs towards it again and then finally it runs through those relative equal
highs, okay?
At that moment, as soon as it goes above it, you start panning back through all this price
running here and find the nearest short-term low because that right there is going to be
your trigger.
It's not that it goes above this old relative equal high and then goes down below that.
That's not it, folks.
That's not it.
You have to see it go below that and displacement with an energetic move, take out a short-term
low.
That's how you filter out these trades that may not be high probability.
So that area right there, as soon as you run above the relative equal highs, in your mind
you're looking for where's the trigger because until it takes out that short-term low, there's
nothing going on.
There's no trade there.
There's no setup there.
Then when there's displacement, that displacement leg in price action, that right there is your
foundation to the setup.
That's it.
Once you have that, then you can go into that area and look for the fair value you got.
That's the logic.
That's the pattern.
That's what you're looking for.
This is if it's bearish.
Now if those relative equal highs would have been traded through this morning, I would
have expected this scenario, okay?
Before it ran those relative equal highs, I was looking for like down here, price was
trading down into that area.
I was showing you my interest today.
I'm watching this, where it was likely to go down to, this is kind of like the low.
In my mind, I'm kind of using it as an example.
What I was expecting price to do once it got down into that fair value gap that I was saying,
I'm watching this, that little arrow, okay, I showed that little gap, I was expecting
this type of movement to set up the run above those relative equal highs.
But there was no movement here to set up that run either.
So two scenarios that I would have loved to see develop just did not pan out.
It just simply wasn't there.
Now I'm going to teach you another approach, and this is kind of like what I was expecting.
Had it panned out this morning, if it would have gave the real set up, which it did not,
I've already shown that, that little fair value gap that I was waiting to see a response
in, it didn't do it, just melted right through it.
But if it would have done this, but this is going to be a sell version, okay, just reverse
it for the going long idea.
If you have an old fair value gap above you, okay, so you have an old fair value gap, and
the market's below it, and it's trading up, and you're bearish, but you think it's going
to go up to that fair value gap, the same logic when it trades up to the relative equal
highs, once it trades into that fair value gap, it doesn't have to completely close it.
If it trades up into it, anywhere between here and here is good, okay?
If it trades above it, you can really make it simple and say, okay, the low of the fair
value gap, treat that like the same logic that you use for the relative equal highs.
Doesn't that make it simple and easy?
That way you don't have to worry about, how hard do I need to know?
You don't need to know that, because you're waiting for something to happen.
What is that?
Once it takes out the low of the fair value gap and trades in there, you go back through
that leg and see, okay, here's what?
There's that trigger.
That's that shift in the market structure you're waiting for.
Then you have the displacement leg.
Once you have that, you can go back in and look for the fair value gap, okay?
That's the two entry strategies for this model.
There's no other way of worrying about, what does it look like this?
Visually, this is what you're doing, okay?
It's simple.
If it feels like it's not simple, watch this part of the video a couple of times, and then
Go back and look at price action in live data and in old backtesting.
Go back and look at old moves, and you'll see this logic is there, okay?
It's algorithmic.
It repeats.
Unfortunately, today, it didn't give me the setup to allow myself to sit down with you
tonight and say, okay, this is what I did, because I was going to trade it, okay?
I was going to enter at the low, run the highs, go short, and ride it down that way, too.
I was going to do it, but nothing panned out.
It didn't mean that the models broke.
It doesn't mean that the models broke.
It doesn't mean that I can't find winning trades.
It just means that the market did not provide the structure to allow this to form.
Does it result in a losing trade?
No, because the logic wasn't utilized that would have put me in a losing trade.
It never formed.
This right here, reverse the logic here.
Apply it.
That's the homework.
Apply this logic here.
Does this appear in the fair value gap that I was drawing your attention to this morning
on the community post?
No, and no one can manipulate and say it was.
It just wasn't there, folks.
It's just a missed move, and there's nothing you can do about it except for beat yourself
up and say, oh, I wish I would have, could have, should have, and that stuff doesn't
make you money, and it doesn't take any more money out of your pocket, so don't do it.
Don't waste time doing that.
It's toxic thinking.
Hopefully, I don't need to bring up all this negativity anymore and address any of it like
this because I'm never going to entertain it in a video again, but I want to lay the
foundation and provide my response to anybody that would think like this or say this, whether
they're trolling, whether they are sincere, whether they feel like they've been victimized.
You've done that to yourself.
If you pushed a button and you entered a trade, you did that.
Nobody in this community, including me, chief of all of them, never told you to buy or sell
anything.
You're never going to have instructions where I'm telling you to buy or sell anything.
It's always going to be study this, observe this, watch this.
That's what I'm saying.
They're not code words for anything.
They're specific elements of study.
Put your attention here, watch and see, observe.
Is there any characteristics repeating with the logic that I teach?
That's not trading.
That's not trade advice.
That's not investing advice.
That's not money management advice.
It's just practicing reading price action.
And that's how I teach.
It might not be for you.
Maybe you want me to drive around in Lamborghinis and lie to you about stupid stuff that ain't
going to work in the market.
That's just not what I'm going to do.
That's not me.
I do things in the charts that make sense.
I teach it.
It's transferable knowledge.
But you have to be prepared to receive it, study it, practice it, and endure all these
times where you look for something to be there and it doesn't happen.
And then the move takes place that you've missed.
That's the test.
Are you going to lose your mind because you missed a big move like today?
I used to do that when I was younger and it got me nowhere but backwards.
Don't live in your losses.
Missing moves is a loss.
Taking a monetary loss in the market is a loss.
Taking a demo trade that's a losing trade, that's a loss.
The mental impact on that, you have control over.
You can decide to amplify every bit of that or you can say, you know what, what can I
take from this so that way I can never be hurt this much again because it will repeat.
But you have to be able to condition yourself so that way when these knocks and trips and
falls and setbacks, when they occur, I've been here before, that way it doesn't completely
derail you.
That's an important lesson.
Unfortunately, no one really touches that because they all pretend that they never make
mistakes and they always catch the runs.
And I'm just not that kind of guy.
I'm honest.
I'm going to tell you.
If that doesn't fit you, again, change the channel.
Until next time, be safe.